[MUSIC]
Good morning, good afternoon,
good evening, my name is Jessica Chung,
I'm an admissions officer at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business MBA admissions
office.
I'm joined by a panel of
my amazing colleagues to
talk about letters of reference today, so,
I want to start by going over what
to expect during our time together.
First I'll have our panelists introduce
themselves and then we'll start with a few
prepared questions just to give
everybody the same base understanding of
the letter of reference,
what is the letter of reference?
What are its purposes, what does
a strong letter of reference look like?
And then we want to turn it over to your
questions, so that Q&A box where you've
been saying hello to us, keep using that,
to enter your questions for us.
You can also upvote other attendees
questions if you see a question that
reflects something that
you're curious about as well.
And overall we're going to spend
about 15 minutes together and
over the course of those 15 minutes our
goals are to help you better understand
how we use letters of reference.
And to provide Recommenders, so
people who are writing those letters for
you, with tips and best practices on
how to write a supportive letter.
And this video will be shared on YouTube
so it can continue to be a resource that
you share with people who are supporting
you in the application process.
So, with that I will turn it over to
our panelists to introduce themselves,
Will, why don't you get us started?
>> Hi everyone, I'm Will one of
the admission officers here,
and one of the qualities that
I value is empathy as well.
>> I love that, yes, I'm going to ask
the rest of our panelists to also complete
the sentence that we've had our attendees
completing about a quality that you value,
Alison, why don't you go next?
>> Hi, everybody, I'm Alison,
with the MBA admissions office,
I would say especially in
the context of letters of reference,
I would say I value transparency,
helps me get to know you.
>> Awesome, thank you and Elisa.
>> Hi everyone, my name is Elisa,
I'm also a member of the MBA admissions
team here excited to join you guys today.
I'm not necessarily related to letters of
reference, but I really value humor and
approaching things with kind of
a positivity and ability to laugh.
Awesome, thank you all, so
let's first get started with some baseline
questions to get all of
us on the same page.
What is the letter of reference and what
is its purpose in the application process?
I'm going to throw it over to Alison.
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, the letter of reference helps us
to see you through someone else's eyes, so
as there's different parts of
the application and so the essays.
Let us see how you see yourself and
the letters of reference,
let us see how others see you.
>> Yeah, absolutely, I think that's a
great short and pithy way to explain what
the letter references as you all
are attendees are asking people and
advocates in your life to write
your letters of recommendation.
Well, Elisa, do you have anything
that you would add to that?
>> I think I might add also for
those of you who may have joined us for
other events,
you are probably aware of the criteria we
use when we're looking at an application.
And whether it's intellectual vitality or
demonstrated leadership or
even just getting to know you
the personal qualities and contributions.
We see a lot of examples of that and the
letters of reference, so when you think,
what is a letter of reference,
what makes a strong letter of reference?
Like Alison said,
we learn a lot about you,
hearing from other people and
obviously the letter of reference,
both of them that you would submit,
play a pivotal role in that.
And they give us some really tangible
examples of the things that we're looking
for especially a lot of times
demonstrated leadership comes out.
We're asking the people who write your
letter of reference to tell us what have
you done and how have you done it.
And that really helps us
understand you as a person and
how you approach it problem solving and
how you get things done.
>> Yeah, I really appreciate Elisa
how you mentioned evidence and
examples, I think,
applying to business school in particular
letters of reference take on
a slightly different spirit.
Maybe that if you were applying to, for
those of you who may remember applying to
college, those tended to be very general,
if you're applying to maybe an academic or
PhD based graduate program.
It's going to be much more focused on
how does this person kind of consume and
kind of produce knowledge,
how do they absorb and share, right?
For the business school context, that is
one element that might be shared in there,
but it's not evidence,
how have you performed?
How have you,
what kind of presence have you had in
especially organizational settings?
That word impact will come up a lot,
like what's the impact you've had,
what kind of footprints
have you left behind?
So, I think over the course of today,
unpacking that will be helpful because
there is a slight different nuance to
letters of ref for business school than
I've seen, even having worked in
other admissions offices before.
>> Yeah, absolutely and I think your
answers also give us insight into what
makes a strong letter recommendation and
I think there should be like a underline,
double underline, highlight,
bolded around evidence.
I think throughout the application
process, we're not just looking for what
you've accomplished, but we're interested
in how you have accomplished that.
And as Alison said, hearing other voices
in your application speak to not just what
you've accomplished, but
how, can be really helpful.
How have you demonstrated leadership
are you able to, creatively problem solve,
you take what's given to you and
see beyond what's given to you?
Do you work beyond the expectations
that are given to you?
Do you make your workplaces more
inclusive, are you able to mobilize and
influence other people to get
on board with your ideas?
Those are all things that are really
helpful for us when we think about your
leadership potential, when we think about
some of your personal qualities and
contributions to the organizations
that you've been a part of.
So, thank you all for that introduction
to letters of recommendation,
I'm going to ask a couple more
of our prepared questions and
then turn it over to the Q&A box.
So, for our attendees,
please continue submitting your
amazing and thoughtful questions and
please continue uploading questions
that you're curious to learn more about.
I'm also wondering if you all,
our panelists have any tips for
helping set your recommenders up for
success?
I think obviously writing a letter of
reference for someone, it takes time,
it takes energy, how do applicants
make sure that their letter
writers are set up for success and
to be the best advocates possible?
>> I can start us off, I think the most
important thing is give them plenty
of warning, plenty of time,
probably how busy your recommender is and
I would say take them out to coffee or
tea or virtual coffee or tea and
Help them understand what the timeline
is and what the questions are.
You can also remind them
of maybe some specific
examples that they might want to include.
As we said earlier,
evidence is so important.
So it's those specifics anecdotes,
details, examples.
So you want to be sure to remind them to
support whatever their
assertions are with examples.
You would be surprised that we
don't often get really negative
recommendations where somebody
is being completely trashed.
That doesn't happen very often.
But more often than we would like, we get
recommendations where they might say,
Jessica is the best person we
hired in the last five years.
Period, end of sentence, end of answer.
No examples of what made
Jessica such an amazing hire.
So you want to make sure
that they include examples.
>> And that was a great example.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
I would also say that for many, we just
talked about how the business school
letter of rec is a little bit different.
So we're going to be asking all of our
recommenders the same two questions that
are along the lines like,
how was this person performed
relative to qualified peers.
Other is,
it tells about a time it was feedback.
So even sharing those questions and
talking through and understanding, okay,
here's a great structure, they're actually
asking for what they're looking for.
And then the other thing you can
share with them is the evaluation
criteria website.
We just talked a lot about
intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential,
but those are kind of squishy words.
And they sound very high level, but
on that website, it actually brings it
down to tangible bite size things
that as they're thinking about,
hey, here are the things Jessica has done.
She's great.
I didn't realize that falls into this
bucket of what they're looking for.
And so that can also help cue them.
And so the types of examples that they
could use to support their assertions.
>> Absolutely.
And that's actually a great segue to
one of the questions in the Q&A box and
Elisa, if you have more to add,
I definitely want to make space for that.
But Cornelia in the Q& Abox asked if
there's a package we can share with
references to give them a sense
of what Stanford is looking for.
I'm going to drop a link in the chats to
more information on letters of reference.
And if you scroll towards the bottom,
you can see some of
the questions that we ask and
more information for recommenders.
So I will drop that in the chat.
Elisa, do you have any other tips for
setting up recommendation writers for
success?
>> No.
I mean, I think well and
Allison touched on the key things and
I would just echo especially what Allison
said at the beginning to give them time.
One it's just a sign of respect
that you're giving them the time,
you're asking for them to take
that time to be thoughtful and
provide specifics that will
help you in your application.
But also,
as many of you may know about any
application process to business school,
but especially the Stanford application,
it's an introspective process.
We ask lots of questions, not only to you,
but to the recommenders also.
And again, just the more time someone can
spend on that, to provide those specific
concrete examples that really help us
understand who you are, is a great thing.
So that was already said,
and I just echo that.
>> Jessica if I just
could add one more thing.
When you're asking them to be
your recommender, and again,
these are probably people you have
mentoring relationships anyway with, so
presumably, you can have
an honest conversation.
If you detect any reluctance,
let them off the hook.
I think the reason we sometimes
get those one sentence
answers is somebody didn't
want to turn down the request.
That they honestly really don't
have time and they feel rushed.
And so you want to make sure that
not only they know you well, but
they're In a position to have the time
to write a thoughtful letter and
are excited to be your advocate.
>> I would also add,
especially if there are folks who might
be writing recommendations
watching right now.
The way we look at the recommendation,
it's for those evidence pieces in context.
So it doesn't necessarily mean
you have to be versed in,
quote unquote business language.
It also doesn't have to
be the most beautiful.
It doesn't have to be
artistic writing at all,
even sometimes factual,
straight to the point.
Here's the impact this person made.
Here's the scope of it.
Here's the scale of it.
Here's what it looks like.
Is this normal for
something at this individual's level?
Have they gone above and beyond?
And here are the reasons why.
And now here are the ripple effects of it.
Sometimes getting straight to that
point is where we find value and
hopefully it helps you save
a little bit of time as well.
I know this can also be a concern for
folks whose
language of writing
proficiency is not English.
And so again, it's not about
kind of how it's written, but
what's written in there in the content.
So know that we are trained and
we work really hard to make sure we're
trying to suss that stuff out and
let the evidence shine.
So just wanted to also put that out there.
I know there's some folks who can be
a little hesitant because they're not sure
what a business school recommendation
looks like or how we use it.
>> And these letters are not long.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but typically
the letters are two to four pages,
would you say at least on will.
They're not long, long letters.
And maybe we should address
if your recommender is
not able to write in English,
what you should do.
>> I mean, [LAUGH] that's a good team.
I think we're jumping right
in some granular thing, so
we can definitely talk about that.
If the primary language of whoever might
be writing your letter of reference is not
English, they could write in the language
they're most comfortable in.
But then we do ask that it be
translated into English upon submitting
the letter of reference.
And again, Will said,
perfect grammar, syntax, and
layout is not what we're looking for.
We're looking for what they're going to
share about you as a person, as someone
who worked in their organization, as
someone who had impact, what did you do?
How did you do it?
What was the ripple effect,
like Will sad, of what you've done?
And that can come through
in a translation, again,
even if their grammar is not perfect.
So for those who are thinking about asking
someone whose primary language is not
English, please don't worry about how
the translation might come across to us.
It doesn't need to be perfect grammar for
us to be able, like Will sad, to see
those examples and to understand the
context of the impact that you've made.
So that is something we do ask for.
And I think this is leading us into, we've
talked about, Allison had great advice.
If you say to someone, hey,
I'm applying to business school,
can you write me a letter of reference?
And you sense hesitation, That's a good,
good first hint to maybe ask someone else.
But I think we should step back and
talk about,
who do we want these letters of
reference to be from and why?
So I think that many of you probably
know if you've started an application or
looked on our web pages that we do ask for
two letters of reference.
And we ask that they be from people
who have supervised your work.
And we specifically asked that the first
one be from someone currently supervising
your work.
And I do see a lot of
questions out there around.
I maybe had worked for someone for
four years and I just switched jobs, and
I'm with someone for only six weeks now,
and things like that.
So we can talk about exceptions to this.
But in general, we ask that for
the first time to be from someone
currently supervising you.
Again back to that criteria
that we're looking for.
Someone who's currently supervising
you is going to be able to tell us,
what have you done and
how have you done it?
What is the impact that you're making in
your current role, in your current job,
in your current organization?
Are you taking advantage of
opportunities presented to you.
Are you going above and
beyond, all of those things.
And we'll get a great sense of that
from someone who currently supervises
your work.
There's a lot of times we generally give
advice around the questions, what do I do?
I just started working with someone
they don't know me that well.
Use your best judgment,
kind of like what Allison was hinting at.
If someone's hesitant when you
ask them to be your recommender.
Same thing here in the sense that you want
to make sure that when you really think
about what is this person
going to be able to say.
And do they know me well enough, that
you're asking the right person, right?
And so you can use your best judgment.
If you have been working for
someone for a short time period, or
perhaps you're working for your mom or
dad, it's a family business.
Or perhaps you're a founder
of a company yourself.
And so there isn't someone that
supervises you in a traditional way,
then use your best judgment.
Who's going to be able to provide
those concrete examples to be
a member of your board.
It could be someone else
that you work with.
It could be the person you previously
worked for since you're only working for
someone for a few weeks.
So again,
think about what we're looking for.
Ultimately, this has to sit
really well inside of you.
We always say the best time to apply is
when you feel like your application is
at its best.
And we would hate for
you to have submit your application and
then wish you had asked someone else,
or had a different letter of reference.
So again, use your best judgment
in terms of who you ask.
But there are a lot of
reasons why we asked for
one to be from your current supervisor.
And I'm going to pass a little,
because I'm talking a lot.
So, I don't know whether Allison
have anything else to add?
>> Yeah, I think Elisa, you're right.
A lot of the questions that are coming up
in the Q&A box are about how to choose
your recommender.
And I appreciate that you went
over what exactly do we ask for?
So two letters of reference,
one from a current direct supervisor or
next best alternative.
Because we appreciate that there are,
as Elisa said, many situations in which
you're not able to ask your current direct
supervisor for a letter of reference.
And then another from somebody else who
has supervised your work in some capacity.
But in addition to that,
do you all have any advice for
how to choose a recommender?
And there are several
questions on this topic.
I think one that has sort of risen to
the top in the Q&A box is from Konica.
Who, I think this is coming from
recognizing that our process is holistic.
That the letters of recommendation are one
of many pieces of your application.
So Konica asks,
do you prefer that similar characteristics
about a candidate or
highlighted in both recommendations?
Are you looking for
different characteristics
highlighted from each recommender?
So, I think again,
kind of asking the question like,
how do you choose your recommenders and
beyond evidence, how do you decide?
How do you think about what story
the recommendation should tell?
And how should it contribute to
the overall story of your application?
Yeah.
>> First of all we have no preference.
And it's really up to you
how you present yourself.
The questions to the recommenders
are on our website so you can see them.
And I would say, be asking yourself,
who can best answer these questions?
And if you're lucky enough
to have multiple people,
maybe there's two that have
more robust examples, or
more examples that they
can include in the letter.
And as far as current
versus previous jobs,
I think that's really how you
want to present your story.
I mean,
if you want to show perhaps growth over
time in terms of your own development,
maybe you want to get a previous
supervisor and then a current supervisor.
If you want to really dig deep into
current impact and accomplishments,
maybe you want two people
from your current company.
And we've certainly seen excellent
recommendations from both scenarios.
And I'm sure there are other
ways to think about it.
But it's really up to you how you
want to present your narrative.
>> Yeah,
I would even make it easier than that.
Sometimes trying to over strategize
might have you trying to find
different people to fit this perfect image
of who you want to present yourself as.
Quinn, one way I think
about it as well is,
sometimes the people who are providing
those perspectives as Alison and
Elisa were talking about,
they're your champions already.
These are the folks who might
be your mentors, advocates, and
sponsors in different facets of your life.
And you'd be surprised at how many people
even within the same organization,
maybe because they're on different teams,
or they're at different levels.
Or if they've worked with
you on different projects.
Even in those instances, they might have
different understandings of how you've
operated and
have had different experiences with you.
And so it really does come back to what
Allison was saying at the beginning.
It's how have other
people been impacted by,
and what was their experience with that?
How can they communicate that to us.
And everybody will do that
a little bit differently.
And we definitely trust you to figure out
who is going to do that best for you.
You may want to strategize if
that becomes overwhelming,
because I know sometimes it can be.
This is going to sound weird because
it's like the one like trust the unit,
like trust your instincts, trust your gut.
If something says, I think this is someone
who can really advocate for me and
it feels like a good choice,
go with that one regardless of their
relationship to your other writer.
>> Absolutely, Elisa,
anything you would want to add here?
>> I think we've covered that really well.
I don't have anything to
add specifically to that.
>> Awesome, looking in the Q&A box again,
and there are a couple
questions about timing as well.
So on the letters of reference
page on our website,
we suggest asking somebody who has worked
with you within the last three years.
And there are a couple
questions about timing,
whether it's okay to ask
somebody from a previous role.
Even going beyond three years ago,
say five years ago,
do you all have any advice on sort
of figuring out the timing of your
relationship with your
letters of recommenders?
Any advice there?
I think it was mentioned earlier, kind of
what you've done in the past as a really
good predictor of how you might approach
problems or lead in the future.
And so when we asked that one of the
letters of reference be from someone who
has worked with you in
the past three years.
That's because we're looking for
current or
more recent examples of what have you
done and and how have you done it?
What has your impact been?
That said earlier I also said,
use your best judgement, so for
instance, if you're going to, maybe choose
someone who is from four years ago.
Or like I said, you're choosing someone
who's not your direct supervisor for
one of those reasons we cited, you do
have the chance to explain to us why.
And that would provide context for
us if you don't, but
there's definitely a reason why we asked
that it be within the last three years.
Again, looking for that more recent
examples of what you've done, and
we're looking for it specifically in
the job you've most recently been in.
But again, you have to use your best
judgment about who you're asking.
I saw I have a question to you around for
instance,
maybe you have been at a company for
a really long time, so
you're going to choose two people from the
same company and that's absolutely fine.
So someone's asking that if those
are the two people who can really provide
the best examples again of what you've
done and know you the best out of
everyone you might be thinking about
asking for a letter of reference.
Then again, if that feels right to you,
that's absolutely fine.
But like we said, you could also choose
your second one to be from someone else
who has supervised you in some way, it
could be somewhere else you use to work.
It could be that someone has
supervised you in an activity
outside of work in some way.
So again, this is really about
you thinking through all
the people you're
thinking about asking and
who might be able to provide those
examples in the best light for you.
>> Those of you who are in client services
business, businesses client might
be really good choice, so
doesn't have to be a current supervisor.
>> Yeah, I'll add one wrinkle to this for
folks who might be reapplying,
you might have asked recommenders before,
you might be asking the same recommenders.
Again, trust your instincts, we have no
preference, if you choose the same people,
you choose different people
because maybe the relationships
in your life have changed.
If you are asking the same people, I
definitely recommend you ask them to write
the letter again from fresh eyes,
even though it might be the exact same
questions, their relationship
the things they have seen you done.
Since you last applied might
have additional information or
ways that they now understand your
impact on in your organization or
whatever setting you were in.
So I think that's one thing I
would definitely recommend,
at least in terms of time recency,
just have them come with fresh eyes,
which would, that's what we're doing.
We're trying to look at who
you are in the here and now.
>> That's great advice, thanks, we also
have a question about deferred admission.
Would you all be able to speak to sort
of the differences between academic
letters of recommendation.
Professional letters of recommendation,
and any tips or
differences that you would want
attendees to keep in mind,
as they sort of navigate their
choices between the two?
>> For deferred admits, so specifically
people who might be at currently
a full time student, who are thinking
about applying to the GSB We evaluate
each application with the same criteria
that I mentioned at the beginning.
So, demonstrated leadership
potential intellectual vitality,
personal qualities and contributions.
So, we suggest that you start
select recommenders then who in
some way have supervised you.
Knowing that you don't have years of work
experience like someone who has already
graduated from undergrad and
worked for a few years but
perhaps someone has supervised
your extracurricular activities.
Or perhaps you've had a part time
internship or even a part time job,
summer internship,
job through your years of college.
There's lots of things that you have
probably been involved in as a full time
student that demonstrate leadership where
you've been able to have an impact.
And so, again,
in those roles has there been someone
supervising you in some capacity?
That might be a good person to think about
asking for your letter of reference,
this could be an academic letter
of reference then in that sense.
Perhaps you've been doing research for
a professor, and
they know you very well and they're able
to speak to the impact that you've had and
what you've done in working with them.
So that's perfectly acceptable to, but
also we encourage you just to think
about extra curricular activities you
may have been involved in internships,
part time work.
All of those are good places to start
thinking about asking someone for
a letter of reference.
>> I would also tie this back to Will's
reminder from the beginning about
business school recommendations
being a little bit different.
So if you do ask a professor or
an academic to write a recommendation,
you want to make sure they understand
they're not writing a recommendation for
a PhD program.
This is a management program
where we are looking for
evidence of leadership potential.
So again, often from professors,
we will get a letter that says,
Elisa sat in the third row in the class,
she got to B plus a midterm.
Here's the syllabus, and
that's not really helpful to us in terms
of assessing your leadership potential.
But if they're talking about impact
you've had, perhaps as a TA or
in the lab or knowledge that you
created that really pushed boundaries.
That's the kind of thing
that can be helpful to us,
nice job with that B plus
at least I heard that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Awesome, thank you all,
let me see there is another
great question in here.
What advice can I give my recommenders to
best boost my chances of being accepted or
to best support them in
writing a letter of reference?
So we talked about setting up
recommenders for success but
are there tips that applicants can give
If recommenders are feeling uncertain or
are not super confident about what should
go in that letter, what can they say?
>> Maybe three things, so one,
definitely share this video with them,
hopefully they'll be able to pull out some
content that will help them understand.
And figure out where some
additional resources are,
provide them with the website,
the evaluation criteria to help them
understand the things
that we're looking for.
And then my third thing would
be if they have questions,
have them contact us directly.
Sometimes things might get lost in that
game of telephone where they're asking you
and then you're asking us,
if they're able to ask us we're able
to make that connection directly.
And if there's any clarification
that needs to happen,
there's not going to be that
extra time lag in between.
And hopefully that's one less thing you
have to do in that that realm of upward
management.
Which again is going to be
a natural part of this.
But yeah, definitely, if they have
questions, have them reach out to us and
we can help out.
>> Awesome, Allison, Elisa,
anything you'd add tips for recommenders?
>> Those are great tips.
I don't feel like I would
add anything to tips but
in general, we want them to be
authentic and true to themselves.
So, this question is kind of
stemming from a place of,
what do you think we want to hear?
And hopefully we've been able to convey
to you today that we're looking for
tangible examples of your impact and
specifics like Allison said, hearing
that Will is the best person I've worked
with in five years [LAUGH] is great.
That's a really positive statement, but
it isn't specific in terms
of reasons why perhaps, and
in terms of kind of evidence of impact and
things like that.
So again, encourage them to be
as specific as possible, but
more so just encourage them to
answer the questions honestly.
We talked about things that we value
at the beginning, be transparent.
There isn't anything,
there isn't a format, or a statement or
something that we're looking for.
We're looking for those examples and we're
really hoping to try to understand who you
are as a person throughout
your application.
And there's lots of different areas of
the application where we find that and
letters of reference
are definitely one of those areas.
>> I would just add too that I
think sometimes applicants and
maybe recommenders worry about,
gee, I better not say that
the candidate ever struggled with
anything or ever grew in their job.
It's like we don't expect
you to spring from
the womb perfectly formed in
this superlative performer.
So, it can actually make a recommendation
more credible if they're
honest about maybe there were areas where
you struggled in your job or things.
I mean, we all have development areas, so,
how you dealt with
constructive criticism and
things that you may have grown from.
>> Yeah, I think at the heart of it,
it's what stood out to them about
kind of their interactions with you.
And that is a very open-ended statement
because that's going to be different for
everyone.
And yes we talk a lot about intellectual
vitality, demonstrated leadership
potential, but we are also not looking for
any particular balance within there.
And so as you're talking to the folks
that you might be asking, or
they're asking,
what are some things to think about,
just let them know that we don't
have a preference for that balance.
Focus on the things that were meaningful
to them, that stood out to them,
and they feel should be
called out in support of you.
Knowing that everybody's letters
are going to have a different balance of
different things.
No two people are going to be called
the best people that they work with for
the exact same reasons.
Or if they are, maybe they've done it for,
there's different ways that
they've been able to achieve that.
So, again, let the recommenders
speak from their perspective,
kind of in their words about the things
that stood out about you because that's
going to be different for all of you.
>> Yeah, absolutely, and
to Allison's point, one of the questions
that we ask in the letters of reference
is describe the most important
piece of constructive feedback
you've given the applicant.
Please detail the circumstances and
the applicant's response.
As you can tell from this panel, all of us
admissions officers were human, they're
humans reading your letters, we have
our own flaws and vulnerabilities too.
And so we know what it's like to make
mistakes and to grow and to get feedback.
So we don't expect anybody to
be perfect in this process.
And one of the things we
are interested in is, how do you grow?
What do you do when you're
giving constructive feedback?
So we're not expecting
perfection in these letters.
We're expecting to learn more about you,
and how you contribute to
the communities and organizations
you're a part of, how you grow.
Those are the things that we're interested
in learning about in these letters.
And as you look through some of
the other materials about the letters
of recommendation,
you'll see exactly what questions we ask.
So that's something you can do to
prepare and that's another way
that you can prepare the writers
of your letters of recommendation.
I wanted to do maybe a lightning round of
what we call tactical practical questions.
And so these might be a little more fast
paced, but I see that there are a lot of
questions about word limits and
some of the more tactical and
practical aspects of writing
letters of recommendation.
So I want to do a little lightning round
of that if that's cool with our panelists.
Okay, this is not something I seeded
beforehand, so I just wanted to check.
So, Katrina has asked a question
that has been uploaded.
Can I ask whether the word limit for
letters of recommendation is a hard limit?
I understand that the limit is
usually up to 500 words, but
I've heard past applicants saying that
the letter of rec is more flexible.
Lightning response, who wants to go?
>> Please stay within
the recommended word count.
We are reading thousands of
letters of recommendation.
And so the more concise and
specific people can be, the better it is.
Sometimes the hardest thing is when
you're trying to find that reference or
that piece of evidence but you're kind
of flipping through a ton of pages.
So, again, on the side that we're humans
reading it, also be gentle on our eye.
Sometimes that size eight font
single space can be [LAUGH]
really tough to really pull
out the media examples.
>> I mean, we're not sitting
there counting the words.
So if somebody goes over slightly, we're
not going to know the difference, but
don't write us a ton.
And I think some people think more is
better and I wouldn't follow that.
>> Make it easy for us.
>> Yeah, make it easy.
[LAUGH]
>> Awesome, thanks y'all.
Johnny asks, one of my recommenders,
and this is also an uploaded question.
One of my recommenders will be leaving my
company next month, so he won't have his
corporate email and phone number,
should I use his personal contact instead?
>> I believe in that instance you
should contact us, because then
that way they can verify it and
give you the full instructions for that.
Nancy in our chat box and Q&A, she is
one of our experts on the process and
can confirm that, but I believe
that might be the way to go there.
>> Awesome, thank you.
>> We want to be able to
reach your recommenders.
So if their work email is going to
be cut off, I would say yes,
use their personal email.
because we want to be able
to reach them if necessary.
>> Awesome, thank you all.
Another upvoted question,
are the recommenders allowed some time
buffer to submit their forms after
the deadline for applicants has passed?
>> Similar to what Will already said
about word limit, we have a deadline for
a reason.
So we do appreciate if they
try to know obviously,
especially in places where
connections might be slow or.
Things like that,
if something does happen,
and it comes in after reach
out to our desk that we do.
One of our biggest pieces of advice at
the beginning of this was to give your
recommenders plenty of time.
And in doing that, you're also letting
them know when the deadline is and
when the time of that deadline is.
So hopefully they're not
writing at the last minute and
frantically trying to
submit at that point.
So our strongest piece of advice would
be to try to get it in at that deadline.
But we do know sometimes things can
happen like power outages, internet down.
Just things that we cannot foresee in that
case well said reach out to our office but
for the most part we appreciate
if they're in by the deadline.
>> And I would say if your recommender
is having trouble, have them call or
email us and at least let us know
in advance that there's a problem.
And we have tech support who can help them
if they're struggling with the interface.
>> I have a tip.
If you're curious about the status of
where your recommend the where that
letter is, go to my Stanford dot
MBA there's an application tracker.
So that you'll know once we receive or
once you complete certain parts, and
that could also help with that
that upward management piece.
>> One last tactical practical question.
In the how to submit section for letters
of reference where advice to determine
whether or not you will waive your
rights review each recommendation.
What should we consider
when making this decision?
>> Well, the first thing to know
is whether you waive your right or
not has absolutely no impact on how
we evaluate your recommendation.
So it has nothing to do with that,
it's more about your right.
If you are admitted, and
you've come a student here,
if you have waived your right.
That means you cannot go
to your student file and
say I want to see the recommendation.
And if tell me if I'm saying it wrong,
but if you didn't waive your right,
then you could go to your student
file once your student here and
say I'd like to see the recommendation.
>> I would say think about your
relationship with your recommender.
Because sometimes if a recommender knows
that you might receive this later on and
that may skew the things that
they're sharing in there.
They might not be as open and candid in
the mic, say a little bit more high level.
So, think about the relationship and
is having that freedom
of knowing that this is going to
be a safe conversation.
That they're having with us through
the medium of that letter of reference.
But they can be that much more open,
truthful.
And to Alison's point transparent from
the very beginning of the session.
Let that be one of your guides as
you make the decision of whether or
not you're willing to waive the right
to see your letter later or not.
>> Awesome, thank you all.
And I just want to reiterate as I think
has come up throughout this session,
when in doubt just reach out.
We know that this process, I know I'm
a poet, and I didn't even know it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Then you did it again.
>> You did it again.
>> We know that this process can feel so,
foreign to so many people,
both for applicants and for recommenders.
So please feel free to reach out to us,
we are here to serve you ultimately.
So when in doubt, just reach out, and
we read all applications in context.
We're not expecting this process
to be one size fits all.
We don't expect people's careers
So be reassured that we read
applications in context.
And if there's anything that you
feel like we should know, as you're,
as we're reading your application,
you can certainly feel
empowered to let us know that.
So, recordings of the session
will be available on our YouTube
channel afterwards, so
you can revisit this conversation later.
If you need to, you can direct
your letters of recommendation.
Writers to this video if you need to,
we have about five minutes left.
So in these five minutes I would
love to hear from our panelists any,
any parting thoughts.
Or if there are any myths about
letters of recommendation
that they would like to miss us right now.
I would love to hear,
love to hear from our panelists.
Final, final words of advice or
any myth busting would like to do
>> Have one mythbuster that Allison
touched on like the saying
more is not better.
And so
that was with regards to a word limit.
But also with the number of letters
of reference [LAUGH] There are some
rumors out there that it
might be helpful to go,
above the recommended two
letters of reference.
And I just wanted to bust that myth
[LAUGH] that more is not better.
So, there's a reason we asked for two, and
we always appreciate when
people do keep it at two.
>> My advice would be, and this isn't
just for the letters of reference,
this is for the whole application process.
Try not to worry, and especially worry
over things that you have no control over.
You don't have any control
over who else applies.
You don't have any control ultimately
over what your recommender writes.
So make your best choices and
then just relax and
forget about it and just don't ain't
Stover over this whole process.
>> And then I'll do a little
bit more mythbusting,
word might be out there that you should
have someone from Stanford or with a big
like famous name writing your letter
because that will help Bust that myth.
It's not about who's writing the letter.
It doesn't matter what their
relationship is to Stanford.
It's what are they writing about
you is that content that evidence,
and sometimes it's maybe that
manager writes about above you.
Who's going to be able to write
the most compelling, thoughtful and
supportive recommendation for you.
So release that notion and
trust the people who have
worked the closest video.
>> Thank you all,
thank you to our panelists for
your incredible words of advice and
wisdom.
Thank you to our attendees for your
really, really thoughtful questions and
for spending a bit of
your day with us today.
We're really, really grateful for it.
This application process
is truly a journey.
>> And we hope that this event is
just one stop along your journey.
Please continue your journey
at my Stanford dot MBA
will mention it as a place where
you can track your application.
Keep track of your letters of reference.
But it also will help connect you with
opportunities and events to learn more.
Which we know is so important as you're a
prospective applicant trying to figure out
whether or not Stanford is right fit for
you and how to navigate this process.
So please continue your
journey at my Stanford MBA.
Where you can create a personalized
dashboard, track your application, browse
courses and clubs, find other events and
connect with student and alumni stories.
This week we'll continue talking
about the application process, and
we have many amazing events.
And we also events throughout the next
couple of months to connect you
with students and alumni to hear about
what life is like at Stanford GSB.
And bad, I'll say my last, thank you.
Thank you so much to our panelists.
Thank you to my admissions colleagues
who have been running the show in
the background.
And thank you to our attendees for
spending some good day with us.
Take care
[MUSIC]